today's episode is going to take us way
back back to the earliest fossils in the
universe as i am an experimentalist i
love to do things in the laboratory to
explicate and explain the most
interesting fascinating and revealing
features of our universe
[Music]
welcome everyone to another exciting
episode of 30 minute thesis
an exploration of some of the deepest
most meaningful concepts in modern
cosmology taught by yours truly
the big bang theory is not just a
wonderful tv show it's also our closest
held notion of how the universe came to
be supplanting previous models such as
the quasi-steady state universe the
static universe and early versions of
cyclical universes to ask a question as
to why we have credulity or belief in
this model we have to look at the pieces
of evidence and there are three pillars
so-called pillars of the big mag model
that we cosmologists adhere to and use
in our daily work to gain more and more
credulity in the model itself and to
also test it for its cracks flaws and
foibles those three pillars on which our
modern cosmological model rests
are the expansion of the universe the
hubble expansion of every single galaxy
with a tiny handful of exceptions 500
billion galaxies are all receding away
from us we want to be able to explain
that in a self-consistent coherent
conceptual framework
the origin of the primordial photons
that i study called the cosmic microwave
background have to be explained and are
explained in the context of a hot big
bang and last but not least a topic we
haven't really touched upon in this
channel at least in the depth that we're
going to go into today is called bbn big
bang nucleosynthesis what does that mean
well we know we're made of matter we
know there's a lot more non-matter like
us in the universe so called dark matter
we've talked about that in many episodes
and we'll continue to do so but the big
bang nuclear synthetic predictions
predict how much ordinary matter should
exist in the universe matter such as the
kind that we're comprised of primarily
the primordial elements hydrogen helium
and their isotopes deuterium tritium
helium-3 give us great bounds and
significant constraints on what the
properties of the early universe were
like the hubble expansion says that
every one of these galaxies in the
hubble deep field are expanding away
from us and every one of them so there's
no center of the universe there's no
place that can call itself the origin
point of the universe we've long ago
dispatched with those notions
that is a pillar dating back to the
original piece of evidence from hubble
and from lemaitre theoretically and
alexander friedman that the universe was
an expansion it was not static it could
not be held to be consistent with a
static universe next in 1965 penzies and
wilson discovered a fossil relic in the
form of photons that were also highly
redshifted dating to an epoch when the
universe was only 371 thousand years old
now where did those come from well the
galaxies that i show you here came from
the fluctuations in space-time curvature
and the agglomeration of ordinary matter
in dark matter reservoirs that were laid
down by curvature perturbations in a
primordial scalar field perhaps
inflation perhaps another field we will
continue to talk about that on this
channel but the primordial cmb
fluctuations provided the seed nuclei
and nucleating science where ordinary
matter could form into galaxies and
clusters of galaxies after accreting
onto dark matter which had to precede
the ordinary matter's existence
so these are fossil relics one is a
fossil expansion of galaxies that are
quite ancient another is even more
ancient photons from the cmb and today
we're going to talk about the formation
of the elements
and how they lead to this picture
of the cosmic web cosmic pattern of
galaxies what they are what they are not
how they are located is a direct tracer
of the properties of the ordinary matter
after all these galaxies in this
millennium simulation are tracing the
position of ordinary matter protons
neutrons the croutons these ordinary
matter particles conglomerate where
there was dark matter that dark matter
aroused in certain locations over other
locations because the presence of
curvature fluctuations creating
gravitational potential wells for the
dark matter to fall into which then
accrete ordinary matter which then make
cmb photons have a harder time climbing
out of the potential wells established
early on in the universe's history
eventually that matter the ordinary
matter ignites and forms galaxies but
where did that ordinary matter come from
to make this incredible tapestry this
rich cosmic web the formation of the
first elements the lightest elements the
primordial elements of nuclear synthesis
so the pillar that we're talking about
today is called bbn
and we have accounted for the others in
terms of a pre-existing amount of matter
we have to have an accessible prediction
to compare with accessible observational
data and you've often heard it said and
i said this to neil degrasse tyson when
i was on his uh star talk podcast i said
carl sagan used to talk about how we're
all star stuff which is true for the
heavy elements in our bodies i see what
you did there you said boom yeah
i put a bang in there every so often the
calcium in our bones the iron in our
blood but where did the ordinary matter
come from that makes up 70 or 80 percent
of our body by mass some more than
others but that mass is in the form of
hydrogen that hydrogen didn't come from
stars it came from the big bang and we
can account for it and test our model of
cosmogenesis by using observations of
how much hydrogen remains to this very
day so we look at primordial bbn
nucleosynthesis what we want to see is
what evidence is left over from these
early epochs this is the process of
fusion of protons of neutrons to form
deuterium heavy hydrogen tritium even
heavier hydrogen
and heavier elements like
helium helium 3 etc lithium they have
very few numbers of protons and that is
going to be associated with their
placement in the periodic table but also
their mass and their mass is determining
their energy their binding energy via e
equals m c squared the most famous
equation in all of science the formation
of these light elements is not perfectly
efficient in fact fusion gives off heat
which is why we think we can use fusion
to power our electrical needs on earth
that's the backbone of the fusion
reactor dream or goal to date we have
not been able to provide a sustainable
solution for electrical power using
fusion bringing together two lighter
things to make a heavier thing with some
binding energy left over in the form of
heat or photons
those photons then later heat up the
remaining
protons neutrons and electrons that
exist after the first few seconds after
the big bang and that heat then persists
as the universe expands and that heat
cools off
from very very strong hard x-rays and
gamma-ray wavelength radiation
to the cmb radiation that we observed
today after expansion of many thousands
and millions of times in our universe
since the first few seconds after the
big bang
so when i teach my students this we are
archaeologists i say we are going back
in time to an early epoch that we can
test the properties of by looking at the
relics that have traveled through space
and through time some of these objects
are still very far away from us but my
colleagues with their powerful
telescopes and their mighty brains have
devised ways to use that information
that we see through telescopes and use
them as time machines to go back to this
epoch of nucleosynthesis and then my
colleagues in the cosmic microwave
background experimental regime we work
on detecting the photon left over and
the combination of the amount of photon
relics plus matter relics tells us
everything we need to know to test the
big bang's predictions of a hot dense
early configuration of the universe we
talk about the radiation in the universe
we know that the number of photons per
cubic meter centimeter
megaparsic all decrease as the size of
the universe increases as you increase
or double the size scale of the universe
the scale factor a of t that tells you
that the volume increases by a factor of
8 2 cubed now photons and other forms of
radiation also suffer an additional
effect which is that their energy gets
redshifted because their wavelength of
light gets redshifted along with the
expansion of the universe
putting these together in the earliest
epoch of the cosmic history the universe
was evolving as a expanding purely
radiation-filled cosmos now when we look
at the early universe we can then make
accurate predictions how fast it was
expanding
from the expansion rate a of t its
derivative a dot or the time derivative
of a we can get the hubble parameter at
any time in the universe's history the
hubble parameter evaluated today is the
hubble constant but we can accurately
test it and trace its history and
calculate how fast was the universe
expanding at extremely early times
noting that the universe is still filled
with photons left over from this period
of time this first few minutes after the
big bang we can calculate the abundance
of radiation and what it must have been
like how hot this radiation must have
been like when the universe was 1
trillion times smaller than it is today
by volume to do that we can ask how hot
was a given photon in the universe
zipping and buzzing around that is
easily calculated from planck's black
body radiation law and we do that we get
an energy scale and that energy scale
depends on time because the universe is
expanding and the photon wavelength is
expanding so each individual photons
energy will drop as the universe doubles
in size it will drop in half
that is simple photon physics in
so-called red-shifted or expanding
cosmological scenarios
so at one second after the big bang
the universe had a characteristic
temperature associated with a
characteristic energy of about three
mega electron volts million electron
volts and for reference an electron volt
is the amount of energy that you need to
accelerate an electron to give it a
potential of one electron volt now
that's not very helpful very useful but
you can think about it in these terms to
take a single hydrogen atom
and hit it with a photon such that that
atom of hydrogen dissociates ionizes
into a proton and an electron you need
to zap it with only 13.6 electron volts
you may remember that from high school
chemistry i sure do well maybe
maybe that amount of energy entails in
comparison to 3 million electron volts
was the characteristic energy of a
photons at this time meaning that
photons could easily blast apart any
atoms explaining why atoms didn't exist
now the question is did nuclei exist the
binding energy of nuclei are much higher
than the binding energy of a proton to
an electron that we call a hydrogen atom
now let me give you some characteristic
energy scales the cern large hadron
collider which is directed by
my fellow narrator fabiola giannatti in
galileo's dialogue on two world systems
you can get a link in the video
description brian keating.com dialogue
you can get your own copy and hear
fabiola the director of cern she
oversees this massive collider that can
replicate the conditions in the early
universe at certain times so she can
replicate the universe with her
colleagues uh if you extrapolate back
the temperature law that i show up above
as a function of temperature the
temperature goes up as the square root
of time as you go back in time and so
she can actually access energies that
are 7 trillion electron volts that's
over 2 million times larger than the
energy the universe was at one second
after the big bang so you square that
million you get roughly a trillion and
you work out the math exactly and you
get that she could maximally probe with
the most powerful collider on earth
an epoch in which the universe was about
a tenth of a trillion of a second old
after the big bang but that pales in
comparison to what we are attempting to
do with experiments like the simon's
observatory which is to go back some 10
to 20 orders of magnitude more in our
search for primordial b modes as we've
discussed in previous videos so how far
back could you possibly go could you go
back to the planck error well that would
correspond to a time and energy scale
that is far in excess of what you could
detect here or use here on earth so
there's no hope to build a particle
accelerator to access the energy scales
that we can get to with cosmic microwave
background radiation experiments or
thereabouts so let's do some simple
nuclear physics let's talk about the
lightest elements on the periodic table
let's compare them to other elements in
the periodic table so atoms which are
just bindings of protons to electrons
with neutrons in the nuclei two
electrons in the outer orbitals those
have characteristic binding energies of
the electron volt scale so to ionize a
hydrogen atom you need 13.6 electron
volts helium has two protons so a single
electron is more tightly bound because
there's more coulomb or electrostatic
force so you need almost twice as much
energy to zap off a single electron
cesium and other things have screening
effects and it makes it easier to
actually eject an electron in a cesium
atom so you can calculate the
characteristic energy scale of a
chemical or nuclear process by its
binding energy to bind an electron you
have to ensure that photons no greater
than 13.6 ev are floating around
otherwise it will get dissociated to
bind the most simple complex nucleon the
deuteron has a characteristic binding
energy as well so these nucleons when we
come together we make nuclei those
nuclei have
two properties that are associated with
them their atomic mass number which is
the number of protons plus the number of
neutrons symbolized by capital n for the
neutrons and capital z for the protons i
don't know why it's not p but it's not
uh the atomic mass number a is z plus n
very simple math
so z determines which period in the
periodic table it's in and the number of
isotopes is determined by how many
different permutations of neutrons still
have the same atomic number see still
have the same atomic nuclei the same
number of protons for all intents and
purposes we will only concern ourselves
with the first say five or six elements
on the periodic table because those and
their isotopes and there's several
isotopes of many of these nuclei they
give us enough information to constrain
the properties when the universe have
this characteristic energy of about a
few mev million mega electron volts the
nuclear binding energy for deuterium is
the first one we're going to look at
binds the galaxy together we're going to
ask when you bind together a nucleus how
much energy would be released if you
were to break it apart and if we look at
the lower right corner this is taken
from my past guest and friend barbara
ryden's wonderful book introduction to
cosmology you can calculate what is the
binding energy
b divided by the atomic number that
tells you something about the stability
of that nuclei that nuclei will be
determined by sometimes having enough
neutrons to keep the number of protons
bound stably because you have to supply
an additional force to overcome the
coulomb repulsion between protons so
helium for example has two protons how
could you possibly get two protons to
stick together if they have positive
charges they should repel the answer is
you need some neutrons around and those
neutrons have opposite isospin charge if
you like and that allows the up quarks
and down quarks in the right
configuration to attract together
additional protons to the neutral
neutrons by going inside if you like
detecting the swirling process of quarks
and the binding of quarks and that's
what causes them to stick together so
stable nuclei are plotted here as having
solid dots there are iso isotopes and
there are unstable nuclei plotted here
as well and when you get to something
more massive than iron that is the most
stable atom in terms of the maximum
binding energy per nucleon once you try
to exceed that you have to then supply
more energy to get fusion to occur then
you actually get released you do get
energy released from fusing together say
uh nickel 62 but actually the amount of
energy you get out far pales in
comparison to the energy you put in
therefore there's not enough heat
produced by the star's core when it's
synthesizing this and so it eventually
explodes and
blows apart and what's called a type 2
supernova the meteorites that i like to
play around with and often give away if
you join my mailing list
briankeating.com list so people can win
a little scrap of an exploded star which
has nickel iron 58 and other isotopes in
it not dangerous don't worry but those
come from the fragmentation explosion of
a gravity bomb that we call a type 2
supernova and that's what happens when
you try to make heavier nuclei now let's
go back we're not talking about stars
today we're not talking about heavy
elements like iron we're talking about
the lightest elements on the periodic
tube so nuclear fission occurs typical
binding energy of about the mev scale
less than about 10 mev
millions of electron volts so we can
form deuterons when the characteristic
photon energy is less than the binding
energy of that nucleon and the nucleon
has a binding energy of about 2.22
mev so as long as the temperature of the
universe on average
is lower than the binding energy of
deuterium or these deuterons the
universe can form copious amounts of
deuterons however eventually the
universe gets quite cold and there are
no photons with that temperature to
break apart any deuteron so eventually
this is going to stop but there are
other reasons why it stops even before
that that sets the amount of deuterium
that remains in the universe after a few
minutes
after the big bang and we can observe
and go out in the universe and count
large distances high redshift
equivalently or early look back times we
can detect these deuterons at high
redshift
then we can use that to compare with
what the predictions would be based on
the observation of the amount of photons
and protons and neutrons in our universe
today
so the binding energy corresponds to a
temperature of about 3 700 degrees
almost 3 800 degrees and that's an age
in the universe that's about 300 seconds
after the big bang that was fast but
we're talking about five minutes after
the big bang the deuterium can form in
large amounts now that assumes that
there are enough
nucleons of the neutron type to exist
and i've talked in this channel about
the decaying of neutrons neutrons decay
in about 800 seconds on average so that
means by the time this the universe
cools enough that you can start making
copious amounts of deuterium there have
been many decayed neutrons protons don't
decay the neutrons decay and so there's
not that many of them left
almost a full half of the total amount
of neutrons are gone by the time the
universe is cool enough to start forming
deuterium so it's actually said to be
quite inefficient the universe has only
about one quarter left over of these
deuterium or is produced and and so we
actually have about three quarters of
the universe just in single protons
which we call hydrogen now another
element that we can look at is element
number two on the periodic table helium
helium has a symbol in cosmology called
y
i don't know why it has that symbol but
it does and so we can calculate how much
helium is left and compare that to the
abundance of helium that we see in the
universe taking into account that stars
like our sun do produce helium that's
how helium got its name helium stands
for helios the greek god of the sun how
did they discover helium on the sun
before it was discovered on earth they
went at night no that's an old joke some
helium that's made and if you go through
the calculation precisely we predict a
primordial abundance of helium of about
25
it's actually a little bit less than
that so we have 75 percent hydrogen
about 24
helium and that means everything else
that we're made up of in the entire
universe by mass is less than one
percent
of all the mass density and ordinary
matter in the universe forgetting about
dark matter which dwarfs ordinary matter
by another factor of five what we're
made up of is so irrelevant to the
overall chemistry and mass in the
universe that no amount of uh overeating
and binge eating will protect us and
prevent us from being completely
irrelevant and a mass skill somebody
needs therapy
so when we look at how the energy of
deuterium can be uh converted to a
binding energy meaning that if you zap
it with enough energy it will shatter
apart into proton and two neutrons same
thing can hold for an individual neutron
you can zap a neutron apart a neutron
has a binding energy if you like the
neutron decays in about 880 seconds
so in about 300 seconds we have a decay
of nearly half or let's call it close to
a third of an entire half-life so that
doesn't mean a half or even a third of a
half have decayed we can calculate it
exactly
but we can look at how this process of a
neutron decaying
into a proton electron and electron
antineutrino for lepton conservation how
that is associated with a binding energy
and we can calculate how that occurs and
that tells us about the stability of
neutrons and we can associate a binding
energy with that as well
so we can use that factor and calculate
the amount of
neutrons that are existing and that'll
take us from 300 seconds back to about
one second in the cosmic history when
there's enough energy to shatter apart
neutrons into protons and neutrons and
electron anti-neutrinos so at times much
much earlier than the half-life of the
neutron there were about one neutron for
every five protons so that means at most
you could make a neutron plus a proton
which we call a deuterium nucleus and
there'd be left over for unbound protons
so there's almost no fusion of most of
the protons in the universe by number so
when we look out at the universe we find
if we do the calculation correctly we
can predict how much helium there should
be very rough estimate gives you an
estimate of about one-third using the
calculation i'll leave it up there for
the aficionados to go through
and if we calculate the fraction of the
neutrons that are still remaining we do
this calculation accurately we end up
with a fraction of about somewhere
between 0.24 and 0.245 ish so it's
extremely accurate then we just have to
go out and measure before stars started
to form these vast lyman alpha clouds
clouds of hydrogen and helium that were
existing after the big bang we can
measure that there's also another
isotope of hydrogen which is even more
exotic it's actually radioactive called
tritium i don't have access to that it's
incredibly dangerous so i won't be doing
any experiments with that so what we
want to look at is the abundance at
these different signposts mile markers
not millions of years ago not billions
of years ago we're talking about 13.8
billion years ago one second after the
big bang is one milestone how many
neutrons were left after being
dissociated perhaps by high energy
photons then at 300 seconds and then
finally
looking back at their leftover protons
and neutrons and electrons that were in
existence when the cmb itself formed so
we do that we can calculate very very
accurately how much there should be left
today this abundance shows the amount of
energy density in the form of mass for
different objects in the universe
starting not including hydrogen because
hydrogen will be off the charts here the
first in the split graph shows you a
very large abundance of helium helium-4
there's also helium-3 down much much
lower abundance there's deuterium which
is the third most abundant of all nuclei
in the early universe we can compare
that
and then we can go even further down to
look at lithium and that gets really
hard to look for primordial amounts of
lithium but we saw this as a function of
the baryon to photon ratio which is
indicative of the fact that the universe
was producing
copious amounts of energy when these
light elements are fused together they
give off energy that energy is in the
form of photons those photons ride along
and expand along their wavelengths as
the universe expands from one second to
380 000 years after the big bang so in
summary the primordial relics of photons
and the earliest combinations of protons
and electrons are the most ancient
fossils that we can detect and measure
to this very day we look at the
abundances of these different elements
in the universe and we correlate that to
predictions of when they left the
nuclear furnaces that produce them when
we go out in the cosmos we can then
compare the abundances at very high
redshift which is not equal to looking
back at one second or even 371 000 years
after the big bang but we can go back as
far as we can make the assumption that
there are no stars producing these other
elements like deuterium certainly stars
aren't really producing deuterium but
they do produce helium before the first
stars were formed we can look at those
heavy gas clouds look for their material
composition compare that with the
results from the theoretical models that
we've just talked about refine our
models and then eventually we will get
to a place where we can predict the
abundance of all the ordinary matter in
the early universe and can then use the
abundance of ordinary matter to then
trace the properties of dark matter
which then traces the properties of a
structure formation of curvature and
eventually perhaps of inflation itself
that's for a future video for now brian
keating thanking you for attending this
class for course credit and what i call
30 minute thesis
if you like this video make sure to
click here for another video in the 30
minute thesis collection and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]